Narrator: GREAT BRITAIN NOW...
THIS IS HOW YOU
HIGH FIVE A BEE.
WHERE RICHARD BROWN IS ABUZZ
ABOUT HIS NEW BEST FRIEND.
Richard: HEY, BEE. HIGH FIVE.
Wrigglesworth:
I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE.
I'D LIKE TO SEE SOMEBODY
FIST BUMPING A WASP.
Richard: HEY, BEE.
HIGH FIVE.
TOTALLY FAKE.
I GIVE THIS VIDEO A "B."
Narrator: SO ARE RICH
AND THE BEE REALLY BFFs?
Richard: HEY, BEE. HIGH FIVE.
ALTHOUGH THIS CLIP MAY
SEEM "UN-BEE-LIEVABLE,"
IT'S 100 PERCENT REAL.
THIS MIGHT LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE FRIENDS.
BUT THIS BEE IS
NOT BEING FRIENDLY.
QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
Bondar: HE'S ACTUALLY ACTIVATING
A DEFENSE MECHANISM IN THE BEE,
SOMETHING CALLED POSTURING,
BASICALLY THE BEE'S WAY
OF SAYING, "GET OUT OF HERE."
Ruben:
IF RICH KEEPS GETTING CLOSER,
IT MIGHT PUT UP A SECOND LEG.
AND EVEN CLOSER THAN THAT,
IT COULD ROLL ON ITS BACK
AND PRESENT ITS STINGER.
THIS IS NATURE'S
CLEAR WAY OF SAYING,
"HEY, I HAVE THIS SHARP THING.
COME CLOSER,
AND IT WILL BE IN YOU."
Bondar: GENERALLY SPEAKING,
BUMBLEBEES ARE NOT
AGGRESSIVE INSECTS,
AND IN FACT THEY PLAY
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ROLE
IN POLLINATING MANY
OF THE FRUITS
THAT WE LIKE TO EAT.
SO DON'T ANNOY THEM, BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT GET HURT AND HUNGRY.